my name is Stephanie Kim I work at
algorithm eeeh we're a small start-up in
Seattle actually right down at the
market which is pretty cool I'm a
developer evangelist and software
engineer there but I kind of more play
data scientist a little bit too I'm the
founder of the Seattle PI ladies
location and former organizer I handed
off the baton to a couple of wonderful
ladies Wendy and Aaron
if you're ever in Seattle definitely
check us out we've got a really good
group of ladies and we open it up to
anyone who actually wants to come
regardless of gender so it's just a
little spiel about me that's actually a
picture of me at high data last year in
Seattle and so that was fun I spoke to
on a similar topic some NLP stuff I do
some machine learning at work I do
lightweight data analysis I also do some
technical writing I rate the documents
documentation so if you're ever on Algar
with Mia and you're like this
documentation sex definitely hit me up
and I'm in charge of it so I'll fix it
now algorithm-- yeah so we make
state-of-the-art algorithms and it's
open marketplace so that means they're
accessible to anyone and you can also
contribute to so it's I guess kind of
like an algorithm github so the cool
thing I feel about algorithm is you can
post your data models and turn them into
an NPI API endpoint just with seriously
a few lines of code it makes it super
easy I'm no API designer and it makes it
really easy to you know say put your NL
ck your scikit-learn even a deep
learning algorithm up on at the
marketplace
turn it into an API endpoint and then
you can consume that you can have other
people consume it and you can charge for
it or make it free for people so that's
kind of cool you can actually get
royalties from your work so this talk I
guess we can move on to the talk and I'd
say it like I kind of glanced over some
of that stuff that you can read my notes
for
more details so this talk is about
triaging feedback form or customer
service data so it's unstructured text
data triaging you know you've heard of
it and you know in hospitals where
nurses what there's a triage nurse and
she'll decide you know what patient gets
wet care in what priority that's kind of
how I felt
we you know we approached we needed to
take with our feedback form data we use
intercom which is a customer service
platform and we respond to messages and
read messages on a daily basis but we
don't really get the big picture so I
wanted to kind of see how we could get a
bigger picture and check out trends so
we could but be better prepared to point
the users in the right direction whether
it's better documentation in a certain
area or just maybe we need it maybe we
were completely missing something on the
UI side and people couldn't find what
they are looking for so that was the
point of this analysis so why would you
want to know what your user so thinking
because we tend to think we know what
our users are thinking but in reality if
you don't even know who our users are
half the time so these are some things
that I have found in previous projects
doing analysis on feedback so I was kind
of this time around I kind of knew like
what I could find so it was interesting
to to see like some patterns that came
up that were also in other projects that
I had done so as I said we read every
messages the message that comes in
through intercom every day and our
customer service like that's a big part
of who we are we really want to reach
out to people and find out what their
needs are but you know it's kind of hard
you know your memory plays tricks on you
and you're like oh everybody's talking
about this one thing and maybe it's
because you had an invested interest in
that one thing and you were personally
involved in the project or maybe it was
just a big demo that blew up
and it felt like oh yeah this is huge
everybody's talking about this well
maybe they're only talking about for two
weeks and so I wanted to look at the lot
more long-term trends and what what I
mean by long-term trends were only about
two years old so not too long but still
you know it's important to try to gain
some insights so what is intercom again
I said it's a customer communication
platform and those are kind of their
three main segments that they try to
kind of sell you on they do like chat
customer support and marketing
automation we mainly use it for user
messaging back and forth and we also
email our users this way when we come up
with a cool use case for an algorithm we
come up with a new algorithm that we are
hosting on our platform and then new
tutorials that come up that we think
that people might be interested in so
here's like a brief synopsis on the on
the methodology so I know it's called PI
data by a lot of this talk was in our PI
data is always open to doing data
analysis and data science in other
languages so I didn't feel too bad I did
a lot of the data wrangling in Python
and used some algorithms on algorithm
yeah mmm I kind of focus was since I
didn't really know I didn't want to
assume anything about my data I was like
okay I'll use some unsupervised
clustering algorithms to try to get some
patterns and then I did some Lda so
topic modeling and then I also did some
logistic regression and some time series
sentiment analysis what's funny is like
you think you're like okay I've got a
decent amount add I think I had like
more like a thousand I wrote 700 I think
is more like a thousand comments and
then after using Python you know and
regex to clean it all up
extract only what I needed and remove
duplicates yeah there were only like 500
five hundred so that was a little bit
disappointing but I don't know if you
guys have heard of intercom or use it
but the data you get back from your user
messages is really dirty it's the most
excruciatingly painful add added I've
ever worked with but I got through it so
I moved on to our to do the analysis
visualization and interpretation those
are the different algorithms I used on
algorithm yeah
Python as I said was just general data
cleanup and so yeah I used the lemma
tiser the part of speech tagger so I
only cuz I only wanted nouns because I
was generally interested in the topics
of course I used everything else for
sentiment but I actually used l da r l
da one of our Lda algorithms for kind of
an exploratory process because it is
like three lines of code pretty much -
to get their results I was like okay
well I want to know if this is even
going to be useful I knew that I didn't
have a ton of data so I didn't actually
know if I'd come up with any useful
topics and the reason I moved to are
after I realized okay this actually
could be helpful was because of the
posterior probabilities which I use to
predict new topics off of my test set of
data so it's kind of using the test the
best tool for the job sort of attitude
and these are the different algorithms
that I and analysis that I ran on are so
my review is but she she she had a rough
time before I cleaned her up
um actually I didn't clear out someone
else had to go through this process but
yeah so that's my data before and that's
my data after as I said anaconda is
really it was painful it was I use JQ
which is a JSON purse or for bash to get
my data through intercom
filtering out a little bit definitely
had its own pain points as since I wrote
and then I filtered out you know some of
our all of our admin messages and then
there's some fun stuff that's some of
the responses were in the body of the
user message had to filter that out with
some regex it was probably the worst
dirtiest regex i've ever written but it
happened so i think already kind of
covered that you know what i used as far
as only nouns were used i did i
mentioned i removed duplicate messages
but I also removed sentences shorter
than four words and words order than
three characters so to get the data in
our friendly mode for natural language
processing which disclaimer this is the
first time I've used our for natural
language processing I've used it for
other things but you have to turn it
into a document term matrix and it's the
same thing I think and I'm not gonna
remember the right name and Python but
there's there's there's a similar
function that doesn't I thought so it
mathematically describes the frequency
of terms occurring in documents we use
tf-idf
from and I removed sparse there's a
remove sparse to City reductions per
city I can't remember the function in
the our function but it'll help reduce
any take out any documents that only
have a few terms that you're not going
to be interested in so here's my first
lovely plots this is kind of a more
exploratory you know part of the process
well the whole project is exploratory
analysis but our makes it super super
easy to do any plotting so I've done it
I've used matplotlib I haven't used
Seaborn but I've heard it's pretty good
our just honestly well using our studio
it makes it so fast and easy to you know
get your plots up and
it's a little bit more painful to get
the data the way the library needs it to
be but so these are the 15 most frequent
terms and you can kind of see that Aaron
image are really sticking out there and
we had a demo a colorization demo that
reached a lot of people and it was great
because you know they're all there's
there are all these people super
interested unfortunately they're you
know like we're looking for an app that
did this for you you know they weren't
developers
we're developer platform so it was
reaching some some people that were
having trouble even just using the demo
so that's kind of why we had a lot of
image and colorization topics when it
was just a brief snippet in in their
time I did remove words like work
algorithm photo those were more than
double what any what the next most
frequent word was so it was just
creating a lot of noise obviously our
product our algorithm so it just was not
pertinent no actually that thank you I'm
I didn't yeah that'd be really funny if
they did um no it's the canonical form
of data yeah so you'll see like ah I
can't remember what API is it is kind of
funny to you so yeah I didn't switch him
back because that would just be a
painful process but no that's yeah good
catch on that one
so yeah the little em'ly Tizer
does that against my better judgment I
added a word cloud because some people
like them probably the same people that
like pie charts probably no one in this
room likes either but I did it because
it's super easy in our again you just I
mean it's like super painless a few
lines of code to get a word cloud going
and in business ops
people like them um so here's a cluster
dendrogram and I kind of went through
these slides at work and no bidding I
think maybe one person I had ever heard
of them it's like oh okay
so I think they're really useful some
people don't um have a hard time you
know kind of interpreting them but I
find them very useful because and
they're used in biology a lot because of
the hierarchical structure but I
definitely find them useful because you
can kind of see like the relationships
between the different clusters and how
they relate to each other so and if you
don't know anything about gender grams
so the branches represent relationships
between the groups of terms and the
branches are called
leaves and then the leaves are the the
actual labels so you can see you from
like left to right how they relate to
each other and also height if they're
closer together so see the email product
website search video see how they're all
kind of tightly nested together in
height that means they're more closely
related and and they're and they're more
closely related to company and service
than they are say air which is again
moving left to right so it's kind of
cool because instead of just seeing like
topics like a topic modeler would give
you or you know k-means cluster
algorithm would give you you can really
see how they relate to each other see at
the end you can see the image color
colorizer picture it's very clearly the
demo that we did on color the
colorization demo on there's some
interesting in the middle like more user
account groups and and I thought that
was kind of interesting and so what I do
like with these kind of exploratory
unsupervised Algar
them sigh I do this and then I'm like
okay well that's great but was that
really tell me it doesn't tell me really
much at all except that there's there's
these interesting groups that come up so
then I then I do some basic information
retrieval with unigram soreby grams and
pull up the actual documents that these
some of these four groups fell into oh
right so I originally looked up how to
do this in Python and I looked extremely
painful then I found at the lake so I
did find some code that looks like it
would work that looks like it's less
painful to do but I am I didn't run it
so I don't know this is this is how you
would make a dendrogram in are pretty
simple pretty straightforward I added
like the very basic things that you need
to do to to get it in the right you know
data format um I actually did not use
this is you know like 20 my you know
percent might be pretty common for a
large corpus mine was fairly small mine
was already fairly sparse so I didn't
actually use that low and Python again I
did not run this code but I took it from
this this site here and it's tutorial
and they had been doing a lot of
different things in between doing
dendogram so this is kind of what I
dropped through and decided okay this
looks like it would create a dendogram
the count vectorizer is the same as the
document term matrix in in are so it
looks actually pretty similar but i just
don't quite trust that this works
because everything else I read was just
like this huge you know script to get
tender grams to work so my coworker
after I was talking about this he we
actually are bringing our to our
platform we already have Java Scala
we arrest Python
I think that's Elliott and then we're
bringing our it's in beta mode right now
do you want to be an our beta tester
just let me know and he's been he had to
learn are kind of apply to build the our
client to get it supported on our
platform so he was like oh I could
create an algorithm to you know let you
build in our dendogram on our platform
and this is all the filming code that
you would need to run it pretty much
it's in it he's not a data scientist or
data analyst and so he didn't really
know like the customizable features that
it would need so I'm kind of helping him
make it a little bit more robust so um
another unsupervised algorithm k-means
and so with the elbow method and trial
and error I found that three clusters
worked pretty well you go to five it
breaks down image and air into two
separate clusters and then the rest one
cluster Erin image did seem to kind of
be somewhat tied together I thought this
one was fairly interesting because it
had a kind of hodgepodge but video and
search really close together and so
product website emails so I thought that
was kind of interesting I'm trying to
keep my eye on video stuff because we're
just kind of starting to play around
with more video algorithms so anytime
that has popped up I'm like mmhmm I
should look that up and see what people
are saying about videos and then the
other ones kind of a mess of all things
developer credit code call those are
really generic terms that we're gonna
see that don't really give us a whole
lot of information so i i've never had
the great luck with k-means really
bringing me any useful information i
keep using it and being hopeful
and maybe it's just the unstructured
text data maybe it's not you know might
corpus are too small but I keep going
and I keep trying I have done
scikit-learn or K mean since I could
learn and honestly are I mean I earn a
scikit-learn or neck-to-neck on like the
ease of use but again our in our studio
come in ahead on the ease of
visualization I remember when I used in
scikit-learn you really have to you know
you have to write a little bit more code
to get your labels to matte to print out
your labels and to actually match them
up on the plot with the data point so in
in this one R is a little bit easier
because a lot of times I mean you
definitely want to visualize your
k-means oh and are actually I should
point out there's also ways to plot it
three in 3d so that's kind of cool
that's just adding a cluster and so
remember I said most everything was done
with just nouns because I was looking
for topics I added verbs in and it
definitely it created clear clusters
actually for this one so it's always
good to play around like with your your
corpus and say okay well I'm really
interested in topics but sometimes
that's just not enough information for
the algorithm so I thought this was a
little bit more helpful call companies
service make it looks like there's maybe
some business outreach that it's
happening and maybe intercoms not the
best way to go that to you know let
those people communicate with us so
possibility for like an actionable
insight is that we can create like a
special email for them for business
outreach because we do get a lot of
those three on our comm and they do give
this send us duplicate messages pretty
often so
the clusters oh yeah sorry it's probably
yeah it's really tiny so with this one
there's I know that yeah that print
actually I apologize I should have made
that font quite bigger um so the bottom
1 cluster 3 spread it has call company
service make and that's the one I was
talking about it's more kind of business
oriented business outreach that we get
on intercom the upper left one number
four image air colorize which I did
mention that you know colorization demo
we're getting people from Jeannie Allen
mention it in the genealogy newsletter
so you're getting a lot of 80 year olds
who are adorable that saying that they
wanted to colorize their black and white
photos actually pretty awesome but
that's you know I mean they can do it as
much as they want on our demo but we
don't build apps so we couldn't and then
number two which is the pinkish one that
one is data SCI user picture question
supports and account so basic user
account stuff I don't find that one
entirely helpful there might be some
issues it does make me wonder and want
to investigate whether people are having
problems understanding their account how
to interpret you know like the account
the profile page so that's definitely
something to look at so again it just
gives you kind of a focus and maybe
pulling up manting I know those
documents that those terms occur in and
then the one big green one over there
there's product email website
information credit learn read add page
that one kind of looks more along the
lines of the documentation and tutorials
and it doesn't give me a ton of good
insight about what possibly it could be
going on so that one's not it's not as
helpful does that answer your question
yeah it's only apologize it's teeny-tiny
so hopefully this is clear the nice
table so Lda results again I said I
tried Lda on algorithm I have a couple
Lda algorithms had actually really good
results there but didn't have the
posterior probabilities to predict any
new topics from unseen data so I used
ours implementation and and I do feel
like that happens with everything I've
done I just take I mean it is a
statistical tool but it does take
everything a step further and I would
love to see you know second learn and
pandas and in other python libraries do
the same thing and intake you know what
they're doing is great but just take it
a step further and give you maybe some
more meta data and so I just kind of in
my notes I just kind of need some
paraphrasing and quotes about Lda
because it's kind of a I mean I'm not a
statistics planation z' and I mean I'm
pretty good about reading academic
articles but the LDA ones are they could
be a little bit painful but so it's just
trying it's a topic modeler and it's a
way to you know find sets of topics that
occur in documents and I used Gibbs
sampling so that's just a way to sample
from slices as does so it's a way to
like get a better random sample and then
again I was just used looking for topics
general topics to where I could dig a
little deeper I was finding trends
between the dendrogram the k-means and
the LDA results obviously topic for kind
of you know eat that one in the
background but
topic 3 is is a little bit the same as
topic for its again the colorizer
some of the confusion around how to use
it because the target user wasn't
exactly who we expected it to be that
was playing around with it so number two
topic input credit product company air
like the the results weren't weren't
super great and that's probably just
because of my lack of data and the lack
of time span but credit was kind of
interesting to me because we are like
our platform is based on a credit system
I've mint permits oh dang I need to
hustle up ok so anyway here's malady a
results the first ones the most
interesting to me because video and
search keep kind of popping it together
so I really want to look at like what
people are talking about with video
again I got the I used are for the
posterior probabilities
I ran the so you don't have to run your
all your data through the LDA model
again you can predict the topics off the
unseen data so I did that and I came up
with these are just like the top seven
but documents and it labeled them as one
topic but first the first topic that the
LDA model came up with I do want to show
you something cool and it's kind of nice
that I do have this set up so this is
something that again differentiates our
and and using pandas and scikit-learn
and everything it gives you this library
LGA vis is super great at visualizing
Lda data you can look at the different
topics the most relevant terms change
the lamda metric and kind of see like
what let's see if I can find a word yeah
okay so site the term site appears and
gives to topics so it's a really cool
way to visualize that but since we're
kind of in a hurry
sentiment algorithms I didn't have
enough data and I didn't have time I
can't see you that sorry oh okay she's
keeping me thanks
okay so sentiments I didn't have enough
data or time to label so I used one of
our algorithms and what we have a lot of
sentiment algorithms on algorithm yeah
and there's I used forecast in zoo in
our I've used time series in Python
they're both pretty great and pretty
easy to use I don't really have any
thing to say about one versus the other
our has forecasting functions so you're
able to forecast all the this is using a
smoothing function a basic exponential
smoothing function this is for negative
sentiment after smoothing the Holt
winters filtering it also is a smoothing
function and Holt winters that blue line
is the predicted forecast for that time
period not ahead of time but for that
time period and then you can there's
another another function for Holt
winters that allows you to predict in
the future it is about I think four
point two positive frequency for the
next five months you can you can an
ultra if you want it like the next two
years or in the next month and so that's
pretty nice it's very customizable and
negative was around two point eight
counts we're done sorry
so I didn't get to logistic regression
or the wrap-up but I will
all I'll put the slide deck up and share
it and I won't take out my notes or
anything so you can read everything that
I was thinking well while building this
also there's resources available and
before you leave there's a code for to
try algorithm-- yeah and you get five
thousand free credits every month and
then here's 100,000 extra credits with
this code alright thanks guys